when we think about the Amazon we often
think about this on the left industrial
scale agriculture on the right as a
massive tract of rainforest managed by
indigenous tribes Brazil has hugely
increased its production of soybeans and
beef these are the issues we often talk
about and I went into the Amazon to
report on them but when you get on the
ground you realize this is also a human
story the Brazilian government has
cracked down on illegal deforestation
but there's still money to be made in
clearing land the region remains rife
with poverty and this can lead to often
violent conflict these environmental
enforcement officers are burning an
illegal camp to the ground across the
road as a patch of deforestation that
they had spotted via satellite
I watched as this man was interrogated
the officers went through his home they
confiscated two unregistered chainsaws
and a gun but it was never clear whether
he was responsible for the deforestation
that took place poverty remains an issue
and people are still moving into the
forest this family told me that gunmen
came and knocked down the walls of their
house these gunmen they said were
employed by a local ranch indigenous
tribes are still fighting to protect
their land and in some cases resettle it
this Siobhan Tate tribe got their land
back but when they did there was little
forest left on it
Brazil has rained industrial-scale
deforestation but pressure on the forest
is only going to increase from roads
ports and dams like this one Belo Monte
which will be the world's third largest
when complete local residents and
indigenous populations are protesting
Belo Monte even today they fear it's
only going to export money and
electricity to the industrialized South
in many ways this is a war over natural
resources and it's not likely to end any
time soon
you